saudi arabia has reduced the sentences
of eight people involved in the murder
of journalist jamal khashoggi in turkey
last year five of them were given the
death penalty for the killing but that
has been cut
to 20 years in jail the others have been
given sentences
of between seven to ten years khashoggi
was murdered by a saudi hit team inside
an islam bull consulate in 2018.
saudi arabia refused all calls for the
men to go on trial
in turkey khaled jashan is executive
director of the arab center washington
dc he's joining us now live by skype one
would imagine that saudi arabia
feels that this in some way draws a line
under the incident but does it do that
for the friends and family of jamal
khashoggi
uh certainly that's what the uh
intention or the the declared actually
a statement uh by the prosecutor's
office uh in saudi arabia uh announced
uh today
that this closes the case privately and
publicly
uh forever but with all due respect to
the prosecutor
that is not the case uh certainly uh not
in terms of the political implications
of the case and also on the private
level in terms of the family
and friends of jamal khashoggi first of
all i think
that the way the saudis handled this as
a form of peace meal justice kind of
retail justice if you will
uh they are prosecuting today
eight people are of 21 or so we do not
know who they are they did not allow
international supervision credible
international supervision to participate
in the proceedings
uh we need to see the details of the
proceedings who are
these eight people uh sentenced five of
them to 20 years that's fine but then
who issued the order i mean did that
settle the fact that
uh there are some high-level officials
involved in this case that did not solve
the the problem at all and most
importantly where is the body of
jamal khashoggi if they have
investigated the perpetrators
and found them guilty and sentenced them
then i assume that they have found out
uh what happened to jamal khashoggi's
body and
and that has not been revealed yet
given the lack of transparency in this
process that you you've mentioned how
significant is it that saudi arabia
actually reduced the sentences of eight
of those people
five of them had been given the death
penalty as we mentioned that's been cut
to 20 years in jail
i think the whole verdict seems to me to
have
been manipulated in a way they used of
course they hid
behind a fig leaf that according to
practice legal practice in saudi arabia
the family has the right to commute
any sentence and the family has issued
such a declaration most probably under
the rest
uh i i don't think it was done uh freely
knowing the family uh and and knowing
uh jamal so i i was surprised by that
and and i'm sure this is basically the
rationale uh for reducing uh these
sentences however the sentences
are final according to the prosecutor's
office and they have to be enforced so
that remains to be seen
we appreciate your time thank you very
much indeed for joining us on al jazeera
thank you